something very special here on cbs
morning something you will only see on
cbs mornings it is one of the final
interviews with the beloved actor and
comedian bob saggett you remember saget
was found dead in his hotel room last
weekend he was just 65 years old
shocking find behind his wit and persona
on air and in front of the camera he was
also haunted for years by a devastating
personal loss the death of his older
sister gay from a little-known disease
saggett became a champion of fundraising
and research for that disease it's
called scleroderma
just weeks before he died saggett spent
a day with our doctor john lepuc in los
angeles for one of his final final
conversations about the disease and also
how he personally used humor to cope
with his loss and john joins us this
morning you've said this is one of the
hardest pieces you ever wrote i was
riding it through tears i really i
really was and when i sat down with my
close friend bob saget last month i
never imagined it would be the last time
we would be together
a serious topic was on the agenda but as
you'll see
bob never missed an opportunity to
lighten things up
well let's start it off you and i know
each other we're buddies yeah
when did you realize you were funny
i thought it was funny
when people were laughing me i was like
four years old when we sat down in los
angeles last month bob saget showed me
how being funny helps him roll with the
punches
[Music]
and we are getting a lot of airplanes
it's okay
and this guy's having a new muffler put
in but we didn't meet just to have a few
laughs
bob wanted to share a personal story of
loss that had affected him for almost 30
years i had a sister who passed away
from scleroderma it was a three to four
year process and she was gone
and i
couldn't bear it his older sister gay
seen here with her son adam was only 47
years old when she died in 1994 from
scleroderma i can't get the images of
the end of her life out of my head ever
what were some of her symptoms she had a
lot of fatigue
um
her body she said it felt like her skin
was on fire
she went to
regular medical doctors that said that
it could be lupus it could be mental
illness it could be epstein-barr so it
was sort of the lit named everything
except what it was
scleroderma literally means hard skin
it's an autoimmune disease where excess
collagen causes tissue to lose its
elasticity
symptoms include tightening of the skin
finger and toe pain arthritis muscle
weakness and trouble swallowing it can
also damage internal organs especially
the lungs
it can be a very
terrible
multi-system disease but not in every
patient dr fred wigley is a professor of
medicine at johns hopkins university who
has studied scleroderma for 45 years you
see those dilated capillaries dr wigley
is trained to detect the tell-tale signs
of scleroderma the drugs that we have
now clearly work better when we see
those patients at the very early onset
that time when things are just getting
started in the united states an
estimated 300 000 people have
scleroderma 80 percent are women most
commonly ages 30 to 50. for unclear
reasons the disease is often more severe
in people who are native american or
black i could hardly lift my legs they
were heavy as i was going up the steps
my fingers were cold my face started to
swell up
like gay saggett cheryl adams williams a
dentist saw multiple physicians before
receiving the correct diagnosis i
couldn't hold the small dental
instruments to do root canals
and my hands were swollen they were
inflamed i couldn't bend them at all
after she started taking medication to
suppress her immune system her symptoms
completely resolved this is your sister
yeah
she has an angelic look about her i mean
there's something very
sweet but when gay saggett was diagnosed
much less was known about the disease
and how to treat it we were
all in the room
when she let out her last breath
and if it i don't know how to explain it
but it felt like
i mean i'm gonna go all
woo-woo here but it felt like the soul
going past us
literally felt it i felt my hair kind of
move
um
you know and being an actor that's a
very important thing if your hair gets
out of place
so even at this very serious moment
humor comes in humor is the only way my
family survived it is so healthy to
laugh
and i'm out there doing it and i know
it's healing for people we've already
just now raised about six hundred
thousand dollars through laughter and
star power bob saget raised more than 26
million dollars for the scleroderma
research foundation john stamos of
course
george lopez has always been there
dave chappelle john mayer we're just
asking you to give to the scleroderma
research foundation robin williams did
the event seven times he just any time i
asked him he said okay chief whatever
you need
i can't watch what happened to my sister
happen to more people if i can do
anything
and raising awareness is one of the
things that gets you there
and for for me it's
it's an homage to her
and somehow telling her that her life
had a real purpose her spirit clearly is
here it's in you whether she's
physically here or not let me be so bold
as to say i think your
your sister would be really proud of her
kid brother
thanks for saying that i um
i have a lot to live up to i feel like
to really do her justice is to really
make huge strides in the next decade or
two
and to really help these sweet innocent
victims with this disease
my sister should not be dead
and that's
that's one of the things that's kept me
doing this will keep me doing this until
i'm
gone i just i'll do it when i'm gone
oh my goodness john the book the irony
of this piece you know he did this piece
clearly i know you all are friends but
he wanted to bring attention to
scleroderma yeah and so that's why he
did the piece and now in his death we
are all learning more about scleroderma
that we had known before it's so ironic
to me when did you shoot that interview
december 6th just a month ago and that
last line i'll do it when i'm gone which
is good which is what we're doing
and i think when he said that he sort of
realized he had said i'll do this until
i'm gone i'll do this when i'm when i'm
gone
listen no one could have anticipated his
death the thing that strikes me about
bob's second i'm so sorry i never got a
chance to meet him but the outpouring of
love and support for him and talking
about how kind he was how sweet he was
and what a decent human being i've never
seen an outpouring like not from just
comedians either from all different
types of people
who came in contact with him he was a
love he was sweet he was emotionally
intelligent he was a mush and he would
be so
happy
that we're talking about this finally
the scleroderma research foundation
which is so important to him they got a
million and a half dollar matching gift
after he died wow go on our website you
can see how to how to find more
information i also like what he said
laughter is healing yes i honestly
believe that yeah
absolutely i did think it was
interesting he made a joke in that
moment you pointed it out that seems to
be who he was you know he said it and
then he waited and then he couldn't
resist yeah i know this was tough for
you john thank you i know it was thank
you so much i promised him no thank you
did you delivered you did deliver